you will sell so much better if you let
a couple people go that you know it's
not going to be a good fit for because
then you know why you're doing it
because then you have more conviction in
yourself that it's not that I just sell
every person with a heartbeat I sell the
people that I think really need this
thing if you sell someone and then think
gotcha you're not gonna make it one
you'll Foster a whole Army of people who
hate you but secondly like if you have
any ethics at all it starts to eat at
you sales is a dance not a fight if
you're ever selling a physical
environment you always want to be on the
same side of the table because it really
signals what the relationship should be
which is we're on the same side of the
table here I'm trying to help you make a
good decision and this is the thing
about having Integrity as a salesperson